why do you want to join consulting why
do you want to join this firm please
guide me through your cv so in
consulting interviews questions like
this will be often asked as you know
consulting interviews have also other
parts such as case interview sections
but these more personal fit related
questions definitely are important and
often people underestimate how relevant
they are so this video focuses exactly
on that some questions that are more
related to the personal fit so welcome
to another coffee break here on my
channel firm learning my name is
heinrich i'm a former mckinsey
consultant and i want to help you to
become successful in the first years of
your career so structure the video in
the following way for you first i will
share some overarching considerations
and tips on these personal fit type of
questions clearly this will not only be
relevant for consulting but also if
you're interviewing for a corporate job
or maybe even a banking job and then i'm
going to go into a couple of very
specific questions that you will
frequently hear in these types of
interviews i'm going to share a couple
of tips on what you probably should say
also what you likely should not say and
i will also provide an answer of how i
might answer these questions in a real
interview situation and also just to get
this straight in the beginning i would
never claim that i'm the biggest
interview master of all i would never
claim that the way that i will teach
this to you in this video is the one and
only way you can be successful but i do
think that there are a couple of
considerations that will make sense for
you as well so let's think for that and
let's dive into it
hi pleasure pleasure to be here thank
you for inviting me yeah great let's sit
down
so let's start with some overarching
reflections on personal fit type of
questions and first of all i want to
talk about a misconception that i often
perceive when people talk about this
topic and this is the personal fit means
that every single consulting firm out
there has their own type of consultant
that they want to hire and they will
look whether you are this very specific
type that fits the criteria of this very
individual firm and frankly i do not
think that this is correct i do not
think that the typical consultant that
for instance mckinsey would hire is very
different from the typical consultant
that boston consulting group or bain
would hire right i do think that
personal fit is rather homogeneous among
these firms i don't think these
differences are that pronounced in my
mind personal fit questions are about
something aids and to better understand
this try to put yourself into the shoes
of an interviewer who will often be a
project lead or partner of that
consulting firm what do you think will
be important to that interviewer when
the interviewer evaluates a candidate
with whom he or she conducts the
interview so in my opinion the main
question that these people want to
answer is what would happen if i take
this potential consultant with me next
week on my next project if i sit him or
her in the team room if this person is
doing his or her job if this person sits
in front of a client for the first time
will this person be able to do the job
will this person be able to represent
him or herself and the firm in a great
way in front of the client or will this
not be the case when you answer
questions are you perceived as confident
or rather insecure
and if you take all these boxes if you
really portray yourself as someone who
could really do this job well then yes
you will have the personal fit to be a
consultant at one of these firms and
again i don't think that these criteria
are very different comparing a firm like
mckinsey with boston consulting group
bain or any other of these firms let's
start with question number one and this
is why consulting why do you want to
become a consultant why do you want to
join this career in the first place so
what most people likely will answer is
talking about the learning opportunities
talking that you're intrigued about
getting to know so many different
industries so many different functions
in a rather short amount of time of
course i hope that also by watching
videos on this channel or so you
understand a bit better what a
consulting career would be all about and
what you might find fascinating about
that and sharing exactly that surely
would not be a bad idea and of course
the person that it is and the less
generic it is the more sense it makes
what's always strong here is to be able
to draw on past experiences so clearly
if you already did an internship in a
consulting firm it's great to talk about
that because this also shows that you do
know what you're getting yourself into
that it's not just a crazy idea for you
to join consulting but that you've
really planned this out but let's also
talk about a couple of things where i
would not recommend you to say this
things that you should rather avoid and
first thing is about explaining your
motivation due to the exit opportunities
so do not think it would be a great idea
to answer the question why consulting by
saying something like oh i heard that if
i work a couple of years in consulting
then i can exit and then i can have a
great career
so while it's not a secret and what
everybody would understand that many
people leave after a couple of years
probably this should not be your main
motivation to start consulting because
then who knows whether you would enjoy
the actual job as well a second thing to
avoid is to talk about things which you
really enjoy but which will likely not
be possible in consulting and this for
instance is true for people maybe with a
phd with many years of experience in
academia and then in such an interview
say that you really enjoy
working for a long time on a topic
really understanding it to the smallest
level of detail and that this is your
passion i hope you understand if you
watched a couple of videos on this
channel that this just does not resonate
with your reality as a consultant but
now let's look into an example of how
you could answer such a question
so heinrich tell me why do you want to
work in consulting so likely since the
beginning of my studies this career in
consulting really always intrigued me
and what i likely had in mind first is
just this learning opportunity of
working in so many different industries
so many different functions in just such
a short amount of time and i really
wanted to just find out whether this
would be something that i would enjoy
which is also why after my second
semester then i did an internship in it
consulting i worked on a big sap
implementation project and i did learn a
lot of things there and among these
things that i learned i found out really
a second thing that i enjoyed so much
about consulting and this is really
working together with clients
from my reflection so far i think there
are only very very few other careers
when such a short amount of time you can
talk to so many smart colleagues but
also smart clients and really help them
solve their problems this is what i
always found extremely fascinating now i
hope in strategy consulting that now i
even have the opportunity to also work
more on more strategic more conceptual
tasks and projects which i believe i
would enjoy even more which is why i'm
sitting right here today let's move on
to the next question and this is one
where i know that many people struggle
to answer this a lot and this is why
this firm why do you want to join this
specific consulting firm and people
struggle with that because clearly the
differences among consulting firms are
often not that great especially the
differences among firms in the same
niche so for instance mbb firms or maybe
the big four or other similar firms so
how do you approach this and i think
there are two ways to do that the first
may be more suitable for smaller firms
and the other most suitable for larger
firms and probably then there's a third
which you can apply to all of these
firms so for smaller firms these firms
often really have a very specific niche
a focused topic that they operate in
here i'm thinking especially about these
boutique type of consulting firms so if
you're interested to work for pricing
boutique it definitely makes sense to
talk about how passionate you are about
pricing and of course ideally also
underline this with past experiences
show them what you already did in
pricing in the past show them and prove
them that this is really your passion
and then this is really what you want to
do with larger firms what often works a
bit better is to really stress the
opportunities that you have in this
specific firm so for instance if you
join the firm like mckinsey or boston
consulting group you will definitely
have a much larger selection on projects
you can work on on topics that you can
cover now the third approach which i do
think can be relevant for firms of
different sizes is really to leverage
your personal network personal
connections that you have to other
people working in the firm so clearly
it's very strong to stay that you
recently talked i had a long
conversation with someone working at the
firm or maybe you attended a career
event or maybe one of your friends works
at the firm and i'll stress a couple of
things that this person told you about
the firm what the very specific culture
of this firm was something that you
really really liked really enjoyed
because this not only shows that you did
your research but clearly you also
already started building your network in
the firm and this is always a great way
to do anyways so what should you not say
what should you avoid well then here i
have a candidate in mind who might talk
to once and this person said in the
interview that when his main motivation
to join exactly this firm is that he
believed that now for instance mckinsey
is the most prestigious firm right and
this person wanted to join the most
prestigious firm and this was the main
motivation and clearly this is not the
best answer because it doesn't really
come out of the values out of really the
benefits and upsides that this firm can
really provide to you and the fact alone
that you say this even though you could
have said many much more insightful
things also shows that maybe you're not
the smartest person right but not
understanding that this is likely not
the best answer to give in such an
interview so avoid answers like that and
then you should be fine but to
illustrate that let's jump into an
example this way why do you want to work
in this specific firm so surely every
student considering joining consulting
needs at least think about your firm
given that you are the market leader in
the segment the what then really made me
form my decision to apply and to
hopefully work here in the future is
that i talked to a friend and also a
colleague who works in the berlin office
at your firm and he told me a lot about
the culture what it's like to be a
consultant at your firm and one thing
that really stuck with me is this idea
of always the best idea the best concept
winning so what i learned is that
apparently you really have the strong
culture that every single one in the
team room even the most junior
colleagues are expected and encouraged
to contribute to make their point to
think very hard about what the solution
to the clients project would be are
encouraged to speak up in meetings to
really already from day one contribute
to the problem solving process this is
really what i find encouraging this is
what i would love to be in such an
atmosphere and if this is only like
closely to what it's really like to work
at your firm i would love to be part of
that as well last but not least let's
talk about questions like can you please
guide me through your cv or can you
please introduce yourself so these are
open questions that ask you just to go
over your cv provided a summary of what
you did in the past and how this relates
to your current job questions like that
are often used in the beginning of an
interview as an ice breaker because the
interviewer will assume that likely it's
more easy for you just to talk about
yourself about your past experiences
than directly jumping into a case so
what i would recommend you to do are two
things first prepare an answer to that
at home don't sit there surprised by a
question like that and then just like
randomly talking about a couple of
things which you did in the past because
this likely will then come across as
rather random not very structured not
very professional and second also be
open to then transfer into a
conversation with the interviewer maybe
the interviewer will ask you a question
be then open to answer that and then
evolve also conversation based on that
this really also just shows and stresses
your interpersonal skills that you can
have a good conversation with someone
with a client potential in the future
which will also be likely something that
interviewers will want to see in
situations like that but once again
let's jump into an example heroes way
heinrich tell me a little bit more about
yourself and guide me through your cv so
i was born in berlin but raised in the
west of germany in a very rather rural
area then i decided to study business in
munich probably the main reason being
because munich is just a city that i
always loved but of course the business
school is highly ranked here in munich
as well then we just talked about the
passion for consulting hall was very
early on intrigued to doing that which
is why after my second semester then i
did an internship in it consulting but
then shortly after i also did an
internship at a munich-based ducks
corporation where worked in their
business development function and this
is really also just such a great area to
learn about how you can evolve the
strategy of the company what now next
big strategic initiatives are this is
what i really enjoyed there which is
also part of that why i think consulting
strategy consulting would be an error
where these two things can come together
then in the end of my bachelor i wanted
to do a masters supply to some of the
big european business schools i was
always intrigued by finance this was
always a topic that very interested me
during my undergraduate degree i never
really was that much into working and
actually investment banking but just the
topic of corporate finance really
intrigued me which is then why i decided
to do a finance master and then i
started studying in the accounting and
finance master at the london school of
economics i had a great year there and
everything that i learned here then just
encouraged me further to really work in
consulting which is why i'm sitting here
right now but now let me hear from you
what do you think about these tips on
consulting interview questions on
personal fit style of interview
questions do you agree do you disagree
do you have any other tips that you
would like to share with the from
learning community i would very much
appreciate that just leave a comment
below in the comment section and as you
know every single comment also helps
with the youtube algorithm so if you
took any value out of this video at all
please destroy the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
the channel to stay up to date on all my
content i'm also present on other
platforms such as linkedin instagram
ticktalk or twitch links to these
socials in the video description as well
also want to say a big big thanks to all
the members of your channel thank you so
much for your support my name is
heinrich i'm releasing new videos every
single saturday so see you again next
week until then all the best to you and
bye
bye